on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan are censored
from New York City
British politics incomplete and utter
meltdown as prime minister Liz truss
resigns after just 44 days we'll get a
fifth leader in six years but what about
a general election
[Music]
and it's a bombshell interview making
headlines across the planet more from my
explosive World exclusive with yay the
artist formerly known as Kanye West
tonight he takes on President Biden
offensively
the president of the United States does
not have meetings with Elon Musk that is
hey here come come come get me that's
[ __ ]
from New York this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening and welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored live from our New York
news center politics can be full of
exaggeration everything is unprecedented
a crisis treachery a war but let me be
very very clear tonight it is literally
impossible to exaggerate the scale of
the Bedlam that this government has
Unleashed in our country in the last few
weeks it's by far the worst thing that
I've ever seen from any government these
useless clowns are basically ravaged our
country
sinking the pound
trashing the market sending our interest
rates soaring and it really comes down
to this
this is a lettuce
and this was the front page of the Daily
Star newspaper
who had a little bet
what would last longer this lettuce or
one very like it or Liz truss the
lettuce
well guess what tonight
the letters won
uh it's almost Beyond parody what's been
going on to lose a prime minister this
quickly after all the chaos we've had
this year but it's real another big
question is should the Tories be trusted
to actually continue running the country
or should as many of the oppositional
leaders are saying there now be a
general relation to sort this mess up
one which by the way would almost
certainly lead to a landslide labor
victory
I've said from the start of the
leadership race back in August the Rishi
sunak the former Chancellor is the best
equipped to run the country in these
very difficult turbulent Economic Times
he's the most experienced in the economy
he understands the economy he seems to
me to be a man of integrity he seems to
be someone who understands what it is to
be competent
he should be the leader in my opinion
but tonight there are calls for Boris
Johnson
the recently disgraced prime minister
kicked out by his own members of
parliament his own cabinet
that he should be the one who returns in
glory just months later to save us from
the Mayhem he started
you couldn't make it up
but that's what's happening tonight and
that is the state of the conservative
party that is the state of his
government that is the state of our
country and honestly I'm glad I'm in New
York tonight
it feels like I've just got enough
thousands of miles between me and Great
Britain to distance myself from this
past but tonight we will be talking to
people who are trapped back in the UK
and can't escape yet
about what's been going on and I've got
my star Stella pack with me here who've
been with me actually most of the week
following this travesty of political
Carnage as it's unfurled
uh
well let's start by joining talk TV's uh
contributor Adam Bolton and talk to
these clinics and Kate McCann they're
both in London so welcome to both of you
uh my sympathy is that you're stuck in
the UK as all this unfurls and you can't
escape to the sunnier climes of New York
City
um let me start with you Adam you you
and I have been around this physical
block for a very long time
have you ever in all your time seen
anything quite like these last few weeks
no absolutely not I mean for a start
we've never had such a short-lived prime
minister uh Liz truss has straight into
the Guinness Book of World Records uh
she's going to be there probably for
less than 50 days uh in number 10 and of
course we haven't had a turnover of
prime ministers with uh what's now going
to be five prime ministers in six years
uh with only a couple of elections in
between uh we haven't done anything like
that since the 19th century you know uh
pre-victorian times so uh it it's quite
unprecedented but honestly appears that
the root of it is I've never seen such
useless people becoming prime minister
uh you know Liz trust was useless Boris
Johnson clearly didn't have the
qualities uh to run a country and to be
a national leader of Integrity yet this
is what the conservative party have kept
on serving up on the electorate because
remember it's the conservative party
which has chosen these leaders uh it's
not the whole country it's not like
winning a presidential election
right well Kate McCann you're obviously
a mere spring chicken compared to Adam
Bolton and I but I'd imagine you would
share his sentiment that this has been
utterly unprecedented I want to show a
clip before I come to you of Liz truss
resigning she hadn't been there long
enough to even get enough emotion about
the job to even cry here's what she did
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
I mean as I think his resignation
speeches go Kate McCann that was
probably the worst I've ever heard from
the worst prime minister had no emotion
nothing heartfelt about it looked like
somebody rather peeved that their reign
was coming to an end after 44 days and
yet I think she was lucky to last that
long the letters live longer
I think you're right Pierce that
actually the emotion that you saw there
was somebody who was pretty cross
someone who was quite frustrated at what
has happened at the way that this has
all come crashing down around her
because I think Liz truss and those in
her inner circle inside number 10 and I
know you may not believe me when I say
this but they thought up until last
night when that vote on fracking
happened that they had managed to get
enough people inside Downing Street
those back bench conservative MPS and
that they'd managed to persuade them
that the project wasn't over that she
could pull this back and that there was
a way to bring the party back together
purely because that none of them really
want to go through another leadership
election again but actually the moment
when this really fell to Pieces was that
vote last night and what happened in the
voting lobbies if you have your Chief
whip walking through your voting lobbies
remember the person in charge of party
discipline essentially holding their
hands up and saying I give up I I can't
do this job anymore whatever I don't
care and walking off walking off so fast
that the prime minister is dragged
behind holding her arm trying to
convince her chief come back that was
The crucial moment I think when it all
just fell apart for this trust and she
is annoyed about that you know there is
a sense of frustration that it's not
really in her eyes very fair that she
thought she could pull it around even
though for most people in the party I
think the writing was on the way I mean
the problem was she was not just in
confidence she was serially incompetent
and that messing up party discipline
last night uh in a vote uh was an
unforced error uh by her and you know
that that's that's the way it goes and
and uh you know what a lot of people are
asking her themselves right now is how
she ever got in that position at all
well exactly I mean I mean look all due
respect to you Miss McCann but she's
angry
this trust is angry that we've we've
finally got rid of her after the most
cataclysmic six weeks in the history of
British politics where she tanked the
pound where she crashed all of our
mortgages we've got to pay thousands
more when she made us a laughing stock
around the globe I mean the idea is
she's angry tonight yeah we're all Angry
mistrust I'm not defending anything
the only thing I can say in her favor
let me just finish is that I am told
this may be the first Prime ministerial
rule of 44 days in history where my
football team Arsenal have remained
unbeaten and won every game throughout
the tenure of a prime minister and for
that alone
thank you Liz trust that's the one
semblance of gratitude I can find for
the otherwise train wreck of her rule
Kate McCann let me go back to you for a
reaction to my rant
thank you peers very kind of you I I'm
not defending her I'm not saying that
she has a right to be angry and lots of
people feel the way that Adam does that
this was a series of unforced errors but
I suppose at the end of the day this is
a conservative party when you step back
which lots of people now think is
completely ungovernable and that's a
really important question when you think
about who's going to lead it next
because even if the party can coalesce
around let's say Rishi sunak with
pennymorden in the cabinet they have to
make such impossible decisions now such
huge decisions which will affect all of
us our mortgages our interest rates any
debt all of our lives but they're not
going to come out of it unscathed Boris
Johnson thinks maybe he might want to
come back I I don't think he'll manage
to get 100 names I don't think he'll get
on the list and that's causing some
anger tonight the party is already
divided and it will be a real struggle
for anybody Now to turn that around yeah
I mean whoever comes in is going to be a
lame duck prime minister and a lot of
conservatives are making their
calculations on who they support
conservative MPS on the basis of who it
would be best to lose under
quickly get it listen I've got to move
on you guys I'll be back I'm sure as we
go forward in the next few days and
weeks the Carnage continues but thank
you both very much indeed for joining me
uh joined now by the conservative MP
Paul Bristow uh Mr Bristow you were a
big supporter of Liz truss and now you
want Boris Johnson back
um I'm not sure I'd be brave enough to
go on television if those were my two
positions tonight
um well that's a perfect introduction
thank you very much peers but um look
I'm a huge uh advocate of listening to
your constituents and uh at the weekend
I was at a Diwali celebration of my
constituency I was at the Great Eastern
run I even knocked on some doors and did
some campaigning and overwhelmingly the
response was bring back Boris Johnson
and so that's why I've come out come out
early for Boris I don't know if he is
going to stand I think he probably is
now entered by the number of MPS that
have come out and said that they would
support him uh but we have to get over a
hundred and nice and silly hope he does
stand and I fully expect him
I I don't I don't know you but I have to
say I think you and any other
conservative MPS who are going to be
calling for Boris Johnson to come back
as leader after what we've been through
in the last few months caused by Boris
Johnson I think you've all lost your
mind I mean the polls at the moment so
the labor party 35 points ahead your
heading for an absolute shellacking in
the next election and if you think the
idea of your savior is the recently
departed and disgraced Boris Johnson who
was found to be a liar found to be a
rule breaker of his own rules who's
still being investigated and indeed may
be disqualified from Parliament if one
of those investigations comes back the
right way if you think that's the future
you're all living in Cloud Cuckoo Land
what's the matter with you well well
Piers um if I may let me answer the
question so I stood in a by-election in
2019 it was quite an infinite spy
election in Peterborough I didn't just
lose I actually came third which was
obviously not a great result
um we were 19 points behind in the polls
but six months later we elected a new
prime minister we elected Boris Johnson
and guess what we went on and we won the
2019 election we're in a similar
situation now where we're we're we're
poor in the polls I think Boris Johnson
has got a proven track record of turning
that around down if you look at Boris
Johnson's government the things that he
did on policy I think you think they
were very very popular we've got brexit
done we uh powered our way up Kobe by
having the earliest vaccine of any major
developed country and we ended lockdown
and obviously we were tough when it came
to the war in Ukraine and we also
leveled up in places like Peterborough
my constituency well we've built a brand
new University and we're going we're
going for high paid High productive and
high wage high skilled all right look to
be honest with you those are popular I'm
having a I'm having a lot of interrupt
I'm having a horrible sense of Groundhog
Day I this is the kind of thing that you
lot we're all saying before about Boris
Johnson and then the whole pack of cards
came tumbling down where Minister after
Minister queued up to sign his death
warrant to get rid of him because he was
such a Scourge on the parties it just
scourged as leaders of the country the
idea that you're all now clamoring for
to come back I honestly think you've all
lost your minds
well you said that before you said that
twice now but what I will say is that
you did see that you did see a number of
people resign but you also saw a lot of
people uh stay loyal to the Prime
Minister I was one of those
um that was a significant number of MPS
I do think he can get onto the ballot
and if you look at the poll of members
Boris Johnson's at the very top what
your what you're citing now are not
policy differences the policies that
Boris um advocated were incredibly
popular that 2019 Manifesto was
incredibly popular I got the best
Evolution let me pick on one of those
let me pick on one of them let me pick
up one of them tell me one good thing
that brexit has done for the British
economy I'll give you 10 seconds
well what brexit did it ended in the
lockdown we had in Parliament which was
starving our country of investment which
was giving no opportunity for us to uh
attract outs like people in his life
country in fact we've actually had more
city of London uh investors come to our
country everyone predicted that we all
go into Frankfurt that just simply
hasn't happened brexit was what the
British people voted for and Boris
Johnson was able to deliver that and I'm
afraid peers we live in a democracy
that's really important
I think listen I've got no problem I
voted remain and I said as soon as
brexit was voted for by the country I
supported the Democratic results and I
wanted brexit to work but as I sit here
now I do not see brexit working and you
lock and all shout as much as you like
that he got brexit done but he doesn't
know she made brexit work and we're
years and years down the line now and it
still hasn't worked so I'm sorry I'm
rather cynical about Boris Johnson from
what he promises and what he delivers
it's a bit like when he sets his rules
in covid and then breaks it but anyway
look uh I listen there's nothing like
loyalty in life so I admire that Mr
Bristow but I am honestly staggered that
any of you think this is a good idea for
your party but if you do that is the
decision for you we live in a democracy
good luck to you thank you for joining
me
thank you
well the leader of the Scottish national
party in Westminster Ian Blackford joins
me now I don't know about you Mr
Blackford but I just think to that I
honestly do think that the conservative
party has gone bonkers
well it has kind of gorgeous penis
there's no other way of explaining it
you know it's actually been really
really so tiresome just watching
politics over the last while we've had a
woman prime minister that quite frankly
should never have been near the place
and I think you've spelled it out rather
eloquently at the beginning of your
program
she's done enormous damage and and the
fact that what we've really had is a
financial experiment
with her Premiership we've had a
financial experiment that's been driven
by those at The Institute of economic
Affairs and by God if we paid a price
for it those are going to be
renegotiating their mortgages I mean
this this is not funny what has happened
and when you when you look at the Tony
Parker I think the only reason this has
taken so long to come to pass is quite
simply because they cannot coalesce
around the candidate to take over from
other split all over the place brexit's
done enormous damage to them this is a
party that's out of ideas that's
entertain and actually it's why we need
that general election because the the
public deserve the right to have their
sea and what has gone on we can't just
you know you know as well as I do the
the I mean look there'll be many people
watching tonight who absolutely agree we
should have a general election But
ultimately that's in the hand of the
conservatives and I I mean they why
would they I mean they know they'd be
heading for an absolute drubbing why
would they call an election so is there
a way that they can before to well I
mean you have had 20 MPS I mean you saw
that last night they were despaining as
to where we are and I would say to them
that put the interests of those that
live in these islands ahead of their own
narrow party interests they know that
this is a party that's right they know
when you were just heard from Kate we
heard from Adam Bolton but whoever
becomes prime minister it's going to be
a lean dot government are we really
going to just Meander through the next
two years with no firm leadership with
no way of leading the United Kingdom at
a time of crisis at home and abroad we
need to be able to put this to the oh
and they need to think about what
they're doing and recognize for them
this is over they need some time in
opposition where they can think about
what their offer is because quite
frankly at the moment it is not there we
need to have that election and of course
for those of us in Scotland I don't want
that ability to have that debate about
our own future because everything that's
happened over the last few years has
been about here so you talk about
respect in brexit and I I take that
piece I understand why you make that
point but those of us in Scotland we
were told in 2014 that we stayed in the
UK that would remain as EU citizens
we've been taken out against our will
and we're we're desperate to find our
way back in that desire to get back into
Europe has become even stronger we can
see that through calling and Scotland
over the course of the last few months
so we want to be able to see thanks but
no thanks to all of this and to be able
to chat our own future you know you know
I talked but I was last on with you
briefly about economic growth we've got
a plan to really drive up between energy
production to drive investment to drive
jobs to drive out living standards to to
improving productivity when when the
Tories were talking about growth there
was no substance to any of that
appearance there was no deal well the
problem is you can as this trust has
proven as this trust has shown you can
talk about growth as much as you like
but if actually everything you do has
the complete opposite effect to growth
then I'm afraid the smoke and mirrors
game is up uh Ian Bradford I've got to
leave it there but I do think you know I
was listening to Nicholas sturgeon
earlier you know one of the other side
effects of all this will definitely
definitely be in my opinion a
strengthening of support for the SMP and
for an independent Scotland because I
would imagine a lot of Scots looking
down on this with utter horror and
saying why the hell have we got anything
to do with this anymore and I wouldn't
blame them even though I don't agree
with you about independence so I think
it's gonna be very interesting times I
thank you for joining me again
appreciate it
thanks Peters
okay let's take a break now but coming
up uh we'll be dissecting this with my
pack Liz truss thought she was The Iron
Lady but she melted like a lead balloon
that's just been put in front of a fire
where did it all go wrong why did it
even happen at all we'll debate this
next as I clutch my trusty letters
Robert pestle
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to Facebook when I'm
sensed from our New York Newsroom
joining me now is the editor at large of
the U.S financial times Julian tent the
former conservative MP Louise Mensch and
political commentator welcome
uh to my guests here here's the lettuce
it outlasted Liz trust Louise mench one
of lettuce lasts longer than a
conservative prime minister dare I say
it you have a problem yeah talk about uh
vote blue go greens
um I thought you're a bit a little bit
harsh on lizard really a little bit a
little bit harsh and let's just
resignation speech we don't want a prime
minister out there blubbing like a sad
school girl you know sometimes it was
robotic it was short it was pointless
yes but she did in the end do the right
thing and when she was always going to
have to go and she at least knew that
she had to go right away now as for
Boris he is incredibly popular with the
members in the country and only one
seriously thinking no I don't no I don't
I think that Boris wants to stop
rishisanak he should be talking to Penny
Morton's people and they should be doing
a deal I don't care Jillian about the
petty politics anymore of this party and
they're feuding I care about the country
and the national interest and our
finances and the fact there's a war in
Europe up and there's a pandemic still
going on that there's this appalling
Financial cost of living crisis totally
great there's and what I'd say is this
what you've basically had is a battle
between the populists and what I call
the technocrats so people who are sober
and competent and really boring so Boris
Johnson total populist a lot of brexit I
would argue was a lot about populism
um I think the live trust came in on a
populist wave yeah
um it's time to get the technocrats
another go
Rishi Suna is a technocrat he can count
yeah I agree I mean Louise I tweeted
yesterday and I repeat it today to me if
you had Rishi soon like as prime
minister purely because of his knowledge
of the economy never mind anything else
if you had Jeremy Hunt staying as
Chancellor perfectly competent it looks
to me and you had Penny Morton come in
his Home Secretary for example or
something like that that to me at least
looks like a competent team well I will
say that whoever wins if they don't
bring in the big beasts from the other
team we're just going to be back here
again in another four weeks right
there's got to be compromised what I
would say though is that while you're
excoriating Boris Johnson's leadership
you had these three people that were all
cheat by gel with Boris throughout his
Premiership Rishi sunnak was his
right-hand man was his Chancellor until
he decided to stab him in the back Liz
trust whilst his foreign secretary
they're all part of Team Boris the owner
but actually it wasn't really the policy
it was Penny it wasn't really the
policies it was actually with Boris it
was the lying and the rule breaking
that's what did it mean at the end of
the day all this internal drama this
kitchen sink drama okay the population
doesn't actually care that much we need
to move on from that it's ridiculous I
mean I agree with you totally appears
it's ridiculous 80 000 people got less
trust voted in there needs to be the
voices of people actually hurt for a
change but the key issue is this Britain
is going to face a winter of discontent
however you look at it I agree it's
really tough what you need above all
else is somebody who could stand up
count that would be a good start and
actually try and rally people around
some kind of vision and unity and shared
sacrifice that is going to be the theme
of the next few months
I'd imagine you're feeling a little bit
smugged tonight in the sense that every
single thing you've said about the
conservative party has now been born
into horrifying fruition in the last six
weeks
the thing is I would be able to enjoy
the spectacle if I wasn't so worried
about what this meant for the British
people as
um has been already said we are looking
at a winter of discontent already with
the increases in Energy prices you've
got reports of people turning off their
heating turning off their electrics and
saving up that little bit of juice on
their lucky card until their
grandchildren come to visit you've got
reports of people riding the bus to stay
warm this isn't just about a Westminster
dog and pony show people are really
suffering and what worries me about the
conservative party is that they've got
two options they've got one option which
is sort of go full-on culture War really
try and give red meat to The Spectator
and no one else then the other option
the technocratic option is the return to
austerity now those 12 years of public
spending cuts have really helped us get
into the kind of mess where we are now
it was just reported today that somebody
has died in the back of an ambulance
because there weren't enough hospital
beds who was the architect of many of
those policies Jeremy Hunt who's being
praised as one of the grown-ups
well actually you know on Jeremy Hunt
I've been very critical of him because
he was the health secretary who failed
to prepare us for a pandemic despite in
2016 having a three-day pandemic
exercise trial run which made a series
of recommendations he then didn't act on
and yet there he was pontificating about
covid for months and several years on
end and I'm like really you were the guy
that didn't prepare us so I think he's a
I think he's a skillful politician Mr
Hunt
um but you know as actually how good he
is I think we're going to have to wait
and see let's come back to Louise and
Jillian here I mean it's not just about
the conservatives now it's really about
the country is that Sarco said a lot of
people are really hurting I mean food
banks the queues are getting bigger
absolutely people are worried about
power literally being turned off yes you
know this winter of discontent could be
one of the toughest Winters we've ever
seen we don't know what's going to
happen with Putin in Ukraine that's
right to make things immeasurably worse
that's right well but the fact is we
would be going through this winter of
discontent even if there was you could
wave a much magic one to make kierstorm
a prime minister tomorrow that would
still be true this is why I advocate for
Penny because I think she is the queen
of compromise you certainly need to have
either Rishi or Jeremy in as Chancellor
but it's Gonna Hurt No matter what you
do that's where we are okay or Jillian
you actually could be very Machiavellian
about it and say we'll go to the country
we'll call a general election we'll get
a massive beating and then the problems
are all yours kirst armor good luck or
exactly or the reality is that isn't
going to happen because turkeys don't
vote for Christmas right least of all
when the turkeys are in the Dory party
and so they're not going to do that
because they know they're going to lose
their jobs
um but yeah the robin line is it's a
poison chalice whoever wins who do you
think should be frankly that lettuce
probably has this would do a better job
for us well the letters probably wasn't
more than anybody else right now because
you know what it's going to be a really
nice you think Penny Morton would be the
best it's the compromise candidate we
need confidence what do you think I
prefer where she's The Knack because I
like people I work for the financial
times I like somebody you understand
and has The credibility and what we've
learned is Bond vigilantes those people
who have the ability to push markets
around stuff they haven't they're not
dead you don't have to bow down to them
but you can't ignore them okay that's
what live trust was trying to do last
soccer if it does become the case we
have a clear storm labor government are
you confident that they would have the
tools in their Armory to fix all these
problems or could it be one of the worst
poison chalices ever handed over
well I think the worst thing that KIA
stama could do is kowtow to the
austerity logic and say that the only
answer is to cut back on public spending
because what 12 years of austerity did
is create some very expensive problems
for us to fix and we did have growth
during those 12 years but it wasn't
fairly distributed what starmart has to
do because expensive borrowing isn't
really an option particularly borrowing
today-to-day spending uh we had a
12-year window of low interest rates we
don't have that anymore what he's going
to have to do is start making a very
clear case for taxing billionaire wealth
and corporate profit and redistributing
them downwards what we've had over the
last 12 years isn't really a crisis of
low growth that we have had sluggish
growth it's been a crisis of money being
taken away out of the pockets of workers
stagnant wages declining worker
purchasing power and being concentrated
in too few hands and I would rather that
KIA starmer has one term in Parliament
where he's able all to take drastic
action to fix some of those things and
set us up for a healthier economy in the
long run than not do enough try and you
know count out this austerity logic and
then end up with the worst of all worlds
which is unpopular not having changed
enough and eventually being booted out
in favor of a much more populist
conservative option
all right and just give me a one-word
response to the potential return of
Boris Johnson
ah I mean the conservative party are
like a horrible hybrid of a female
artist one word
I mean I I gave you a long sigh and I
think that's the only word that's of con
friendly I mean it's it's
a lot of people no there's a word
impossible well why wouldn't sleep it is
impossible that pretty well sums up
everybody thank you very much Jillian
Louise thank you both very much indeed
we're coming next is last words and
Promises questions what pasta la vista
baby but is Boris going to be back now
to terminate us I'll ask his father
Stanley Johnson next
[Music]
[Music]
thanks
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back to Pittsburgh from New
York city so could Boris Johnson really
be back well for me this is a dreadful
thought but the warning signs are here
and this political hero is the Winston
Churchill he famously return to number
10. Boris does like to compare himself
to Roman Statesman Cincinnatus in his
leaving speech who came back as a
dictator by the way Johnson also said
this at his final pmqs
I want to thank everybody here and
hasta la vista baby thank you
nasta La Vista of course the famous uh
signature uh theme speech of the
Terminator you then terminated
everything that he got in his way well
joining me now is Boris Johnson's father
not a Terminator Stanley Johnson uh also
conservative cabinet minister Ann
whittakam and the editor of the U.S uh
sung newspaper Natalie Evans is with me
here in New York so welcome to all of
you Stanley let me start with you if I
may
um I I look I'm not keen on the return
of your son so soon after his
ignominious departure but you are his
father and therefore will have very
different loyalties I imagine but do you
think as his father and as a
conservative man do you think it would
be the right thing for him and the right
thing for the country to even put his
name in the ring again so soon well
peers I got to say I heard your your
rant about half an hour ago so I have no
doubt about what your position is but my
position is simply I'm looking at this
as a voter I'm looking at this he won't
believe this but I say to myself I have
a vote in this election I just got a
message from conservative central office
there I'm going to get an electronic you
know password
um before the end of the week and as a
voter I say well what we want is someone
who's going to do the right thing for
the country I say on this point the
country is probably more important than
the conservative party so yeah and
frankly I have absolutely no idea where
the Boris is going to be accounted in
this election no idea at all but I think
he has a very strong record to be
considered as a viable candidate and I
very much hope he will let his name go
forward so that's why I stand on this
right but it's all right but if he
wasn't if you wasn't your son and he was
another conservative prime minister
who'd had to leave the post in some
degree of Shame voted out by over 50 of
his own ministers would you think that
within a few months of that happening it
was a good idea well he didn't become
Prime Minister given the state of the
conservatives right now it's a good
question and I have looked at this I've
looked at the record and I looked at the
things I absolutely care about and I do
absolutely care about as you know very
well because you've had me on this
program before I absolutely care about
the environment and I think he made a
big effort on the environment not only
with you know the cop 26 which we had in
Glasgow but he's he made a big effort
with the G27 I'm sorry the G20 and the
G7 very big ever he made a big effort on
Kobe it's I look at those things I say
these were serious achievements no I'm
not saying you know I'm not saying that
party yet wasn't a a a a blip but as far
as I'm concerned I think he knows how to
deliver on the environment he knows how
to deliver on the economy and he knows
how to deliver in terms of international
relations so
I I hope he will I hope he will put his
name forward and I I hope that the
parliamentarians who voted for him this
time will realize that you know there's
joy in heaven Over The Sinner that
repentes and I think you'll get
um you can't stop bringing the good Lord
into this uh let me let me turn to Ann
Whitaker and whitakam uh I say this with
great respect but your party is in a
complete state of utter disarray what is
going on
I don't know I mean I honestly think at
the moment I'd rather vote for screaming
Lord such than for the conservatives um
I'm not sure what's going on on the
issue of Boris let me say this that the
one thing that would concern me if he
came back is that we still have the
inquiry being led by Harriet Harman uh
he has no sympathizers on that inquiry
and a lot of people on it who've already
said what they think uh and I'm not sure
that the conservative party would be
wise to have Boris back when that
inquiry could pronounce adversely having
spotted out for some time then pronounce
adversely and we'd have more chaos peers
more chaos so regardless of boris's
strengths and regardless of his
weaknesses I think that is a major
consideration
oh okay let me bring it let me bring in
Natalie uh Evans here from the U.S Sun I
mean it's funny being in New York when
this is all I'm feeling because of
modern technology it doesn't really make
any difference other than you get a
feeling from people in New York wow we
thought our politics was crazy look at
these guys across the pond that's
exactly the feeling and I sympathize
with you and you say it's great to be
thousands of miles away from this I
don't often miss being home and when
this kind of thing happened it's like
okay but I mean yeah it's not very often
that Americans you know they're used to
the world looking at us and going what's
going on in your country so it's quite
nice to be able to turn around and go
hang on someone else has got it as uh I
mean somebody did a brilliant uh tweet
earlier it was actually uh it was a I
think a political journalist from the
Sky News let's see if I can find it
because it was very very funny have we
got it up there on screen
the Sky News one it was it was something
along the lines
he said he said uh my son has lived
through four chancellors
three home secretaries two nearly three
prime ministers and two monarchs he's
four months old
[Applause]
hopefully that summed it up right it
really chaos I mean like we I think we
established before like uh Liz trust his
presence at primary not president that
has census prime minister was for four
scaramucci's
night and he was saying that he actually
feels like he doesn't feel so bad enough
no it makes it look good the son I think
you know trying to embrace this trust
and get behind her but pretty soon I
think we're going to be a bit spiky in
the in the comment pages about you know
what was going on who do you think the
sun might get behind now I mean would
they be tempted to go with Boris or is
it more likely they'll they'll go with
someone like sunai well I mean I'm I
would say Rishi is sort of the the the
well the front runner there but we've
actually been polling our readers and I
mean we might find it's crazy that
boris's name has even been thrown into
the mix today but more than 50 of our
readers actually want him back yeah he's
52 Richie's Italian with 27 right so it
might not be so crazy well it's not I
mean I mean Stanley Johnson I can say my
own son my oldest boy who's 29 Spencer
is a massive die-hards fan of Boris
thinks he was unfairly done in and he's
absolutely thrilled at the idea that he
might be returning in glory well good
for him
moment and then returns hey one good
good Fair eldest son Boris is males and
this is what I think he's going to be
crucial in uniting these rewarding parts
of the Tory party and why do I say that
because he is probably the only man of
the man who pushed for bricks if I
wasn't very keen on brexit you know who
actually realizes now that the crucial
thing is to rebuild the relationships
with Europe we look at the trade figures
now and we realize that as you said
earlier also brexit has not been a good
deal if we don't really make an ever now
to get closer to Europe we are going to
be in trouble and I think what Boris may
be able to do is tone down the response
Reese smog has got a plan now as you
know just the sunset cause any single
law which originated from Europe there's
about 2 000 of them well borrowers have
got to put a software down as a voter
I'm going to say who am I going to vote
I mean I mean look you know what you
know how he can persuade me as a
remainder I have to say although I
respected the result of the of the
referendum if Boris Johnson actually did
come back in charge and said you know
I've had time to think about this brexit
hasn't worked we're going to have
another referendum I suspect the British
people would vote overwhelmingly against
brexit
may not because I'm not actually saying
let's go for another River I am saying
he needs to clamp down on what you might
call the theological ideological view of
certain parts of the Tory party not only
of course about Europe but about China
and so on and so forth so I think in
this sense Boris really could be a
unifier and he's probably the only man
who can bring back these Wind Wings of
the party together he has to dump the
right wing he has to fix himself firmly
in the center
okay let me bring let me bring out and
you've been furiously shaking your head
for the last few minutes was not an
unusual spectacle on my program but why
are you enraged by what you've been
hearing
well quite honestly if that was going to
be boris's program Boris would be the
last person I want back because I think
one of the big problems uh over the last
few weeks has been that we had somebody
uh who appealed to the membership uh on
a completely different program on a very
bold program which he then bungled and
Miss ambled let me concede that but she
had a very bold program and what we've
got now is just more of the same that
was happening before that wasn't
actually getting us anywhere and the
idea that Boris is going to ditch
completely what Stanley calls the right
by which he means that boat program
completely and just go back to where we
were
um I find absolutely horrifying but then
quite honestly Piers I find the hold on
thing horrifying
well you know you know what Anne I and I
I understand that if I was a
conservative honestly I would be ashamed
of what's been going on I saw that clip
of Charles wheeler uh really speaking
from the heart last night which went
around social media and it was really
quite heartbreaking actually to see
somebody that upset about what was
happening with his party but someone's
got to get this thing back on track and
when you have a when you have a lettuce
lasting longer than a conservative prime
minister let's take a little look at you
a bit of Charles Wheeler's uh comments
last name
Walker I've had enough I've had enough
of talentless people
um putting their tick in the right box
not because it's in the National
interest but because it's in their own
personal interest to achieve ministerial
position and I and I know I speak for
hundreds of back benches who right now
are worrying for their constituents all
the time but now worrying about their
own personal circumstances
as Charles walking up wheeler I'm
apologies but uh but the statement
speaks for itself and the whole thing
was worth only two or three minutes but
my God it was powerful and says it all I
think a lot of Tories are in complete
thermal uh my thanks to Stanley Johnson
my thanks to Anne whittakam and Natalie
you're going to say we've been talking
about Kanye West I think after the break
which um the next part of my explosive
more inclusive interview with yay the
artist formerly known as Kanye West
we're gonna run the whole interview
tomorrow night but it's already had a
million views on YouTube just one small
clip so a huge I think interest in what
is coming up tomorrow in our two-hour
special we'll talk about that then
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to Facebook uncensored
live from New York City the first
installment of my explosive World
exclusive interview one of the most
brilliant but controversial artists in
the world yay formerly known as Kanye
West has already hit her a million views
on YouTube he and I went head to head
for two hours yesterday on everything
from anti-Semitism to George Floyd to
White lives matter the tea study War Kim
Kardashian of course his ex-wife Donald
Trump here's a taste of what's to come
in our two-hour special tomorrow
[Music]
the interview everyone has been waiting
for you're being a Karen
Piers Morgan speaks exclusively to yay
explaining his controversial comments on
George Floyd as the most influential
person on the planet I am questioning it
Kim Kardashian would you like one day to
get back with Kim and his anti-semitic
tweet that got him kicked off Twitter it
is racism when you say I'm going down
no it's not interview adjourned and then
he walks out of the interview
and then he walks back in and apologizes
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard Piers Morgan uncensored
exclusive to our special Friday 8 P.M
and there's a lot more where that came
from it was two almost extraordinary
hours I've probably ever had I think as
an interviewer uh yay is no normal
interview subject he mocks my British
accent he Delights him being uncensored
and then really tests the Waters of our
lack of censorship
um he's rude about a lot of people he's
warm in past what I didn't expect him to
be it's funny uh he's outrageous he's
shocking he tries to defend the
indefensible but then apologizes for it
so it's a really fascinating watch it'll
be tomorrow night from 8 till 10 on talk
TV Natalie Evans I mean humans Kanye is
now yay everything about him is kind of
fascinating but he's been through a
pretty awful few weeks of saying deeply
inflammatory things about the Jewish
people about George Floyd about white
lives Matter t-shirts enraging Community
after Community what do you think of him
what's going on with him right now
well I think he's clearly a very
confused very vulnerable guy who I mean
as he said in your interview you know he
he has this huge platform you know he's
he's the most influential person in the
world and
perhaps a mental state he's in we all
know he's got you know mental health
issues he denies he has any mental
illness he said that to me he said his
main problem is sleep deprivation which
might well be the case because he's got
one of those I can tell he's got an
incredibly Restless curious fizzing mind
this is why it goes off on tangential
because it's very hard to interview yeah
it's not a compelling challenge as well
but I think there's something about his
mind it's just not it's not normal
whether it qualifies as mental illness
he says not well I mean if it was sleep
deprivation there'd be far more of us uh
running our mouths on on Twitter and our
social media is there any defense for
what some of the stuff he's been saying
I don't think so no I mean it was it was
fascinating to watch your interview that
the clips that we've seen it was quite a
journey with him you know I mean a
fantastic we'd be very proud of that
over there but you know for him to come
out you know this this whole concept of
I'm fighting fire with fire you know
it's one thing to you know stand your
ground be be defensive
um but he's also I mean he's like a kid
in the playground that's like oh you
know that guy punched me so I punched
him back it doesn't make it right he can
say he's been the victim of racism that
doesn't mean that he should Target other
groups you know it incites hate in
different directions and as someone with
that profile he shouldn't be doing that
yeah no I think it was interesting
because he he started off wanting to
double down everything and was quite
belligerent and almost sort of offhand
about it but then the longer he said he
walks off at one stage giving me an
ultimatum he said I'll only apologize
what I said about the Jewish people if
all these business people who've ripped
him off as he says get around a table
and you know apologize to me but he went
away and thought about it and when he
came back he then actually did Issue
quite a sincere apology to any Jewish
people who've been offended by what he
said and said they weren't the target of
his of his anger I think he's got a lot
of pain and anger going on Kanye from
all sorts of different directions his
upbringing at the breakup of his
marriage maybe not seeing his kids
tonight I don't know but I gotta say
there are moments of great levity in
this interview he's very entertaining
it's compelling to watch and by the end
I kind of felt I I just don't think he's
the Devil he's certainly not the angel
you may want people to think he is
um they're interesting what people think
yeah for sure I mean the the kind of it
was fantastic the way you actually did
kind of tease that uh apology out of him
you know he clearly was not looking to
do that and yeah maybe
storming off again I mean but a lot of
the parts of the interview were quite
childlike well it's a bit what he said
to me you know I'm trying to give him
advice about if I were you I think I
would think about it
and then he says um how rich are you
well not as rich as you obviously you
said exactly so what should I take your
advice is it somehow only money is the
currency for being able to offer wisdom
and I said well why don't you actually
listen to my advice and if you like what
you hear then have nothing to do with
money yeah I mean it's everyone is
perfectly fine to disagree I mean I
completely agree with you he's been
through a lot and he's been through it
yeah on a very very public form you know
it's no easy thing to go through it
doesn't you know what it doesn't defend
me in defense no no you said some
indefensible things but like I call him
out on those and it's an interesting
challenge Natalie thank you very much
indeed good to see you that's it for me
tonight my show our interview yay
tomorrow at 8pm until then whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign